très face aux affaires de violences
policières alors que les procédures sont
souvent longues la justice peut-être
d'être efficace peut-elle faire
triompher la vérité pour en parler ça
vous avez christian saint-palais avocat
un président de l'association des
avocats pénalistes bonsoir à vous m
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés marc
lifshitz secrétaire général adjoint
unités magistrats snm fo premier vice
procureur au tgi de pontoise bonsoir à
vous également merci d'être en direct on
a entendu ses cris 1 tout d'abord le
père de ses deux chevaux via et puis
elle a third adama traoré pour vous la
justice doit véritablement entendre ses
cris aujourd'hui on commence par vous
marquez nif quitte la justice écoute
bien entendu la justice vis au coeur de
la cité et donc la justice entend un
bien entendu mais il faut quand même
replacer les choses dans le l'ordre
juridique normale quand la third adama
traoré dit que la ministre n'a pas à
rencontrer la famille
nous sommes d'accord bien entendu car il
s'agit d'un coup de couteau d'une
entorse à la règle de la séparation des
pouvoirs
mais quand elle dit la ministre devrait
rencontrer le procureur pas plus à plus
il faut que la justice puisse faire son
travail dans la sérénité et la ministre
et qui que ce soit n'a pas à s'ingérer
dans le fonctionnement la justice
en revanche là où il ya une vraie
responsabilité de l'exécutif sait qu'il
faut donner à la justice les moyens de
travailler or aujourd'hui manifestement
ce n'est pas le cas christian
saint-palais la justice aujourd'hui n'a
pas les moyens de travailler vous êtes
d'accord ça c'est un problème bien plus
vaste encore que celui du traitement des
violences policières
oui ça je
je rejoins monsieur le le procureur sur
ce constat la justice manque de moyens
et concernant les condensats policière
il ya autre chose quand même
ce que nous entendons la dendre dans les
deux affaires que vous avez évoqué c'est
le ressenti de deux familles de victimes
deux parties civiles donc aucun et qui
ont le sentiment que la justice ne
répond pas à leurs attentes
alors ça ça n'est pas parce que le parti
a le sentiment que la justice ne répond
pas à son attente que ça signifie
forcément que la justice serait mal
rendue attention à l'interprétation des
choses mais je dois dire quand même que
en matière de violences policières
c'est un sentiment il faut le dire
souvent partagée de ce que la justice
n'entendrait pas suffisamment ceux qui
expriment des doléances à des cas du
traitement qui leur a été réservé par
les comme ici alors il ya sans doute une
certaine solidarité qui existait que
l'on peut comprendre les policiers
exercent une force qui peut être
légitime
les policiers remplissent des missions
difficiles et on peut comprendre aussi
que dans l'exercice de ses missions et
des erreurs soient commises ou des actes
non adaptés et été réalisés ce qui
déçoit souvent c'est la difficulté qui
via lorsque des plaintes sont déposées
que ce soit par l'igpn est parfois par
les magistrats
downtown dans ce qu'est dénoncée oui il
existe des violences policières
cela existe il est normal que ceux qui
sont mises en cause dans ces procédures
se défendent et s'explique
mais il faut offrir une réponse
judiciaire rapide à ceux qui s'en
plaignent
il y va de la crédibilité de l'autorité
de la police et donc de la justice aussi
marqueurs lifting c'est vrai que c'est
une critique qui revient souvent c'est
ce que l'on disait par exemple à notre
invité va les rendre saint-just sont à
l'heure qu'il est lui même
aucun sauf erreur de ma part l'un des
soucis c'est que c'est vrai que voilà il
ya un temps judiciaire qui est très long
et qui sème une confusion quand vous
voyez que dans cette affaire à damas
traoré il ya 2
expertise qui incriminent les forces de
l'ordre une troisième indépendante qui
dit ben non alors on inverse pardon qui
disculpent un les forces de l'ordre et
la troisième qui incrimine justement ces
forces de l'anp voie nouvelle expertise
indépendante demandée par la famille
c'est vrai que ça sème la confusion
forcément et suscite la colère
alors je ne rentrerai pas sur le fond du
dossier pour la raison principale c'est
que je ne le connais pas et vous savez
qu'un dossier d'instruction c'est
quelque chose qui est couvert par le
secret de l'instruction article 11 du
code de procédure pénale et donc je ne
dirais pas sur réagir sur le fond du
dossier
c'est vrai que c'est une illustration
c'est une affaire qui suscite la colère
et on comprend pourquoi plusieurs
expertises la longueur alors il est
certain que la justice doit elle plus
diligente et c'est là où on retrouve le
la problématique des moyens très
concrètement ça veut dire que un juge
d'instruction il a beaucoup de dossiers
souvent plus de 150 avec un nombre
important de détenus des affaires par
définition qui sont graves mais souvent
aussi complexe et c'est vous dire que
c'est les moyens pour travailler sont
très limités ensuite quand il lance des
commissions rogatoires
eh bien ça dépend de du nombre des des
policiers des enquêteurs qui vont
travailler sur cette commission
rogatoire
et tout cela prend énormément de temps
un temps effectivement judiciaire est
très long qui ne correspond pas avec les
attentes les attentes du public
on le comprend et si on veut une justice
de meilleure qualité il faut surtout pas
supprimer l'instruction le syndicat
représente t il pour le maintien du juge
d'instruction mais il faut absolument
lui donner les moyens de travailler
alors les moyens évidemment il ya aussi
maître créant sa peine et ce sentiment
d'impunité qui revient souvent dans les
débats aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
dénoncé actuellement dans la rue vous
êtes d'accord c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui en france
ce sentiment d'impunité des policiers ne
seraient pas sanctionnés
vrai ou faux je me méfie de ce genre
d'affirmation mais si vous me parlez de
sentiments alors oui je dirai que ce
sentiment est très partagé mais même
dans les audiences vous savez assez
simple où est ce qu'ils comparaissent
devant les tribunaux se plaignent de la
façon dont on leur a parlé de la façon
dont on les a interpellés avec une force
qui disent souvent non nécessaire mais
vous savez que c'est un propos qui est
assez souvent balayer d'abord parce que
les juges doivent aller vite pour
traiter certaines affaires contrairement
à ce que nous disions tout à l'heure il
ya des affaires qui sont jugés
immédiatement et je vous assure que ce
qu'ils comparaissent devant leurs juges
ayant le sentiment que les doléances
qu'ils expriment les critiques qu'ils
formulent contre les policiers et qu'il
formule de bonne foi souvent quand ils
ont le sentiment qu'elles sont méprisés
ses doléances
eh bien ça crée un sentiment de rupture
avec la police dans un premier temps
parce qu'ils se disent enfin la police
ne m'a pas traité comme elle le devait
comme devrait le faire une police
républicaine
et puis c'est une déception est donc un
éloignement de la justice qui ne prend
pas le temps soit parce qu'elle n'a pas
le temps je ne le dit a forcément le
contraire mais qui ne prend pas le temps
d'entendre alors ce sentiment d'impunité
il n'est de tout cela oui je suis
persuadé qu'il ya des violences
policières qui restent impunis je redis
qu'il est nécessaire que ceux qui sont
mises en cause puisse se défendre et
dans les affaires donc parlons sur le
terrain médiatique
moi non plus je ne sais rien de cette
affaire l'avocat des familles expriment
ce qu'il a à dire et les mises en cause
doivent se défendre il faut les faire
bénéficier eux aussi de la présomption
d'innocence mais là je parle d'une
manière générale il ya un sentiment
effectivement de l'unité de nos n'écoute
en tout cas de ceux qui se plaignent de
la façon dont ils sont traités alors que
non répond le magistrat force
sentiment d'impunité trois choses sur le
sentiment d'impunité qui seraient
couverts par les magistrats je m'inscris
en faux
nous sommes des praticiens du droit au
quotidien nous entendons des personnes
interpellées nous dirigeons des enquêtes
donc nous savons très bien les services
qui dérape
nous savons très bien les dérives
individuelles et nous savons aussi
enquêter dessus est sanctionné et exiger
des sanctions
aujourd'hui les affaires qui provoque
l'émotion sont des affaires très
médiatisées mais vous avez un certain
nombre de policiers et de gendarmes une
ultra minorité bien entendu qui qui
franchissent la ligne jaune
quelquefois d'ailleurs par un mauvais
encadrement ou alors couverts par
l'encadrement et ils sont sanctionnés
sauf que on le sait que trop peu mais
ils sont sanctionnés régulièrement par
les tribunaux on ne va pas contester
qu'il peut y avoir une difficulté dans
les rapports de la police et de la
population et je crois qu'il faut un
petit peu élevé le débat on a une
difficulté d'abord de ces deux zones de
non-droit dans lesquelles la police n'a
plus le droit de cité
et si vous n'intervenez pas en force les
policiers sont prises à partie ça c'est
une réalité
c'est à dire que la république s'est
retiré de quartiers en difficulté et
aujourd'hui on en paye le prix
et puis vous avez aussi des policiers
sortant d'école des jeunes policiers qui
ne sont pas encadrés par des gens qui
ont l'expérience qu'ils ont finalement
poursuivre leur carrière dans des
endroits moins chaud entre guillemets eh
bien nous avons des bleus en première
ligne inexpérimentée qui viennent
travailler la boule au ventre
ça aussi c'est une réalité mais je ne
contesterai pas mon l'organisation je
représente ne conteste pas qu'il y a un
besoin de formation des policiers
et il y en a un besoin d'encadrement et
pour cela il faut qu'ils aient des
policiers d'expérience qui encadrent les
jeunes policiers qui opère par exemple
dans l'aide dans les banlieue nord de
paris ou des les banlieues nord de
marseille et puis après il faut du
contrôle et de la sanction
à l'aide d'un code
des rondes et ontologique il faut
peut-être revoir justement vous parlez
de travail des policiers sur le terrain
mais c'est vrai que la justice voilà
c'est tout le problème avec cette
question de l'impunité la manifestants
des manifestations de gilet jaune ont
notamment pour le moins écorné l'image
de la police il ya eu huit enquêtes qui
ont justifié l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire mais m
saint-palais aucun policier suspendu
c'est ce genre de bilan qui peuvent
créer la colère selon vous justement sur
si vous saviez le nombre de deux jeunes
de 18 ans 20 ans qui ont participé à ces
manifestations de gilet jaune
il est d'autres citoyens d'ailleurs et
qui voulaient exprimer leur appartenance
à la république en défilant et 1
exprimant des revendications des
citoyens
si vous saviez le nombre de ceux que
nous avons accompagné devant les
tribunaux poursuivi qu'il se tenait
parfois pour des jets de projectiles
avéré pas une ciné mais qu'ils avaient
été victimes de tirs avec la fesse
complètement marché par un tir dvd on
s'est habitué à ce qu'il faut bien
appeler des violences et des jeunes et
qui découvre la vie citoyenne en
participant à des manifestations à vos
paumes que c'est assez quand même
magnifique que des jeunes prennent du
temps pour s'exprimer dans la rue dans
le cadre de manifestations autorisées et
qui sont victimes de ces violences la
voyez ça c'est ce qui crée la rupture
avec avec nos services de police et je
pense que les acquis le monde monsieur
rockeur disais tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait un problème de formation c'est
évident mais il ya un problème aussi il
faut mettre les mots sur les choses
il y à des violences policières il faut
que qu on le glisse et il faut dire que
ensuite les procédures seront menées
puis il faut aller jusqu'au bout et y
compris jusqu'à des suspensions après
qu'ils se sont détendus dans le cadre
des procédures disciplinaires et il faut
arrêter avec le fait de doter d'armes
qui sont tout de même des armes de
violence les policiers qui encadre les
expressions des citoyens l'objet dans
notre débat en tout cas merci à tous les
deux ans christian
saint-palais et marque lifchitz un
secrétaire général adjoint unités
magistrats snm est fou d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous